this week a friend of mine posted ad I
agree
football it was a semi-serious a
timeline of the creative process from
the first moment of the project to the
final deadline at the beginning of the
timeline there was little mark showing
the moment where the project begins and
then there was a huge long stretch of
the timeline maybe ninety percent of it
devoted to the first stage of the
process procrastination according to the
diagram procrastination is by far the
most time-consuming part of the process
it's a complicated activity involving
snacking naps boredom denial guilt shame
and the Internet it takes days weeks
maybe even months or years to finish
procrastinating there are just so many
pictures of baby animals to look at and
so many important things to do like
folding all your socks that have nothing
to do with the task at hand according to
the diagram after you spend ninety
percent of your time procrastinating you
are then ready to enter the next stage
of the creative process panic panic is a
little late procrastination but it's
even less pleasant it involves guilt and
shame but it also involves jitters
insomnia stomach aches headaches and
crazy amounts of caffeine at this stage
in the process you proceed to spend a
lot of your remaining time freaking out
you don't see how you'll ever get done
in time everything seems impossible and
you're so afraid of failure that you
don't even try and then after you
panicked enough when you've arrived the
last days or hours or minutes before the
deadline you are ready to enter the
final stage of the creative process
doing all the work while crying the last
stage is pretty self-explanatory it's
complete misery but then the deadline
arrives and you either make it or you
don't and it's finally all over
that is until you take on another
project and it starts all over again
does this process sound familiar to you
do you sometimes feel disconnected from
your work and stacked and unproductive
patterns of anxiety and fear does your
leg feel too rushed too slow too lazy or
too crazy unfortunately this chaotic
process is very familiar to me and
according to facebook and too many
conversations I've had over the years
with friends and students that's
familiar to many others as well many of
us are pretty productive and
high-functioning people and there are
definitely days when we budget our time
wisely and maintain a positive attitude
and calmly proceed to get things done
but sometimes we don't some days our
life feels like a long series of
impossible deadlines and demands
stretching behind us and before us as
far as we can see we forget why we're
doing what we're doing we feel worn down
by countless commitments and we feel too
far behind to ever catch up and some
days I feel like I'm living through all
the stages of the process at once
procrastinating at breakfast panicking
at lunch crying and working from dinner
till dawn it's a vicious cycle that a
lot of us fall into and I'm going to go
out on a limb and say that this way of
life isn't God's will for anyone and if
you're like me you might be looking for
a way out but luckily for us God has
provided a means of escape
my sermon today is about two things I
spend a lot of time thinking about in my
work as a teacher and writer deadlines
and extensions or to put it another way
it's about deadlines and lifelines
deadlines are the ultimatums that give
us a sense of urgency and life lines are
the means of grace that give us a sense
of possibility and hope and in order to
live the fruitful life that God wants us
to we need both people procrastinate and
panic for different reasons sometimes
they procrastinate because they lack a
sense of urgency they doubt the
importance of what they're doing their
goal seems irrelevant or impossibly far
away they lose their belief in their
work they forget their overall purpose
nothing seems to matter that much but
people also procrastinate and panic
because they have too much of a sense of
urgency the stakes teams so so high the
consequences of failure seems so dire
and their own abilities seem so terribly
limited we were afraid they don't have
what it takes to do what they need to do
and their fear can become a
self-fulfilling prophecy in the New
Testament readings today Jesus and the
Apostle Paul give us two similar stories
about deadlines and life lines these
stories are written to help us break the
cycle of fruitlessness and despair
Paulito Jesus come at the problem from
two angles in order to deal with both of
the major root problems of fruitless
behavior are worried that our work
doesn't really matter and are worried
that we can't do it and it's already too
late
both Paul and Jesus begin by telling
cautionary tales that raise the stakes
and create a sense of urgency in their
hearers Paul tells the story of our
spiritual ancestors the Israelites
wandering in the desert some of the
Israelites lost sight of their glorious
goal the promised land and got stuck in
the day-to-day discomfort of their lives
some of them complained and grumbled and
failed to trust God and they were struck
down in the wilderness these people had
made it out of Egypt and through the Red
Sea they ate miraculous water and manna
in the desert but they never reached the
promised land Paul's story is meant to
jolt his listeners out of their
complacency we may think that we have
time to waste and license to complain
you may think that we're doing well
enough and that our daily pattern of
negativity doesn't matter but we are
God's children and our attitudes have
consequences and instead of standing
around for crass donating and
complaining we need to keep our eyes on
the prize we need to run our race
steadily and faithfully we need to
remember God's promises to us we need to
pursue these promises with all the
strength that we have or else
Jesus's cautionary tale hits a little
closer to home it's a story about the
tower that fell in Jerusalem Jesus tells
us that 18 people were killed when they
were crushed by the falling tower and he
asked us do we think that we're better
than those people who died in the
accident is there some special reason we
feel like our time won't be cut short he
says don't get too comfortable we're no
more special than those people we have
no idea what the future holds and every
minute matters because every minute we
are at the mercy of the unpredictable
world do we want to spend our days in
fear and aimlessness or do we want to
spend them in faith and fruitfulness
there's a reason that the word deadline
contains the word dead the stories that
Paula Jesus tell put our daily walk into
the context of our ultimate end they are
about the ultimate finality of our lives
the highest stakes of our Christian
faith and the seriousness of our choices
they remind us that what we do matters a
lot more than we can fully know but
thankfully Paula Jesus don't end by
telling us about the deadline of death
they use it to get our attention but
then they give us a very different
message a message about life they throw
us a lifeline that we can cling to and
use to pull ourselves to safety
paul offers us a lifeline in the form of
a promise it's a mantra to take with us
as we head into midterms or writing
deadlines or the demands of
relationships or the workplace the
stresses of coping with illness or loss
or any other part of our struggle God is
faithful Paul tells us God is faithful
and God will not let you be tested
beyond your strength with the testing
God will also provide the way out so
that you may be able to endure it we may
be tested up to the limit we may reach
the end of our abilities but God is
faithful God is able and Jesus throws us
an equally sturdy lifeline a lifeline in
the form of a parable it's maybe my
favorite parable ever it's a story about
a fig tree this victory had gone for
three long years without burying any
fruit every year the owner of the tree
had walked to the vineyard looking for a
nice fresh fig and every year the tree
SAT paralyzed and unproductive maybe
making some leaves and flowers but
failing to actually do its job which was
to make figs and finally the owner of
the vineyard said to the gardener enough
already this victory is a waste of space
it's time to cut it down but the
gardener said just give me one more year
I'm going to try to help the tree out a
little I'm going to dig around it put
some fertilizer in the soil make sure it
has everything it needs and at the end
of the year if it bears fruit all as
well and if it doesn't go ahead and chop
it down
there are many things I love about this
story but the thing that I love most
about it is the gardener in most
interpretations of the story we are the
fig tree the gardener is Jesus and Jesus
is advocating for us we may have given
up hope we may have been looking around
the vineyard for the past three years
staring enviously at all the other trees
plastered with figs and we may have been
thinking that we would stay barren
forever and we may have been terrified
when he overheard the owner of the
vineyard talking saying it's time to cut
the tree down we may have agreed with
him we may have thought yep this
confirms what I always feared I'm a
waste of space go ahead and cut me down
but luckily it's not up to us the owner
does not get the last word and neither
do we and as we listen to the gardener
we learn that someone hasn't given up on
us someone thinks we might have figs in
our future and luckily for us the
someone's job is to take care of us his
job is to make sure we have air and
sunshine and fertilizer he wants to give
us another chance to fulfill our purpose
I also love that the gardener doesn't
let us off the hook he doesn't say you
know what figs are overrated who cares
about figs let's forget about fruit
let's just enjoy this tree for what it
is a bunch of bare branches the gardener
doesn't deny that figs are the trees
purpose and i love that the gardener
doesn't leave the timeline completely
open ended he doesn't say just give me
50 more years 50 years from now maybe
we'll see a fig know if it said that the
fig tree might have gone straight from
panic to procrastination and put off
making figs for another 49 years
the gardener knows that figs are
important time is of the essence so he
advocates for more time a limited amount
of time but enough time and then he gets
busy with the plowing and the
fertilizing and this is the hope that
the parable makes possible for us the
gardener's living care and the Sun and
the soil can help to awake in the deep
sense of purpose built into the fig
trees jeans instead of procrastination
and panic the tree will feel a deep
sustaining energy running in its trunk
singing in its SAP budding in its
branches with trust and care and just
the right amount of time figs can happen
Jesus doesn't tell us the end of the
story but that's okay because the story
of the parable is the story of our lives
we are living our lives in the shadow of
one very big deadline and many smaller
ones we may always be tempted to
procrastinate and panic but as Paul
reminds us we will never be tempted
beyond what we can bear and thanks to
the loving care of Jesus we have one
more day one more chance to bloom and
grow one more chance to turn our energy
into sweetness and sustenance one more
chance to turn faith into fruit sisters
and brothers it's not too late but it's
time let's go forth and make figs